[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality the host of the Ken Coleman
show author of the number one
bestselling book from paycheck to
purpose is my co-host today so we
definitely can handle your career job
and work questions along with anything
else you want to throw at us the phone
number is AAA
825-5225 thanks for being there we're
going to start this hour with William in
St Louis hi William how are you
doing a good day I can
how are you
doing good
what's up how can we help
yes I have a question I'm 30 years old I
graduated with my degree in computer
science I currently work in the trade
right now doing foundation repair
and I'm thinking of pursuing a career in
the military but not quite sure if it's
what I should be doing I don't I feel as
though I don't have much of an
opportunity of growth
using either the skills that I've
learned or would like to do them long
term
okay so we have two different factors
there so first I don't feel like I have
opportunity for growth
uh with a computer science degree I that
that couldn't be further from the truth
uh technology is the number one industry
where we stand today and going forward
will continue to be so so the sky's the
limit on technology now in the trades I
would say that's incorrect in the trades
as well but in your particular role as
foundation repair maybe that's true
so that's one narrative problem the
second thing you brought up is uh I
don't know if I want to do them long
term now that's that's what we need to
be paying attention to so is the
military just another option or is it
something that you've always longed to
do you you're a patriot you want to
serve our country in a specific way or
is it just another option that maybe
I'll kick the tires on because I don't
want to do computer and Technology work
and I don't want to be in the trades
what is it
um I've always had to drive to do so
since my senior year of high school and
even through college
but now that I've been
a working professional for this long I I
can't get the opportunity with my foot
in the door to use my computer degree
and like say doing trades it's fun but I
don't I'm not giving any benefits or any
actually any benefits at all okay well
if I offered you a job making 150 000 in
computer science would you be would you
have joy
unless you're a complete Joy but I mean
it wouldn't hurt either well I mean why
why not complete Joy
honestly
so back to the military thing I thought
I heard you say
that you've always wanted to serve in
the military since high school did I
hear you correctly
that's great okay then why what's behind
that
I don't have much goal or general
direction of what I want to do so I just
kind of fall on
you know whatever seems easier
okay that's not a good answer to I've
always wanted to be in the military it's
completely opposite so
um
what you have to understand is is that
there there are things that you do well
those are your talents and then there's
things that you really enjoy doing
and to this point in your life I think
you know what those are so if I
interviewed everybody that knows you
William what would they say are the top
two or three things you do well and
we're talking about a skill set could be
a hard skill or a soft skill what would
they say
I'm not quite sure I'm not I don't have
that many talents
all right now we know what's going on so
here's where we're at Williams so I'm
going to give you a couple of tools that
will allow you to dive into this not
under the pressure of being live on the
air okay I'll tell you about those in a
minute but here's what's going on
something has happened to you
something has been said to you to where
you don't believe that you have anything
to offer
you don't think you have any talents
and that couldn't be further from the
truth
so what we got to do is we got to get
you to a place where you begin to see
wait a second I have something that I
can do well that's come easy for me
people have complimented me on this and
if I'm if I'm able to get through the
pain and through the past and see that
then I can begin to realize oh I have
something that I can do well and when we
get the clues to that there will be
things that we enjoy closely aligned if
not the same thing so stay on the line
and I want to do a couple things I want
to give you the get clear career
assessment and this is a wonderful
little tool of self-awareness once you
to take it and then I want you to read
the book from paycheck to purpose then I
want to schedule a call Austin let's
schedule to have him call in on my show
after he's done both of those things
and we'll work through what we now see
and Dave you know our friend John
deloney deals with this a lot too when
someone feels as though they have no
worth they don't feel they're worthy and
then they have a hard time even
identifying I can do this well this is a
type of work that I can do and
contribute to the world and that's
what's going on with him yeah and then
you fall backwards that's correct
selecting things oh my default right
well I mean you just like take the path
of least resistance it's like I can't
screw that up right I'll go to the
military and they'll tell me what to do
and when to do it right now and that's
not that this is um
Earl Nightingale great motivator used to
say
that you take an 18 year old young man
young woman and they've got the whole
world in front of them there's nothing
but hope there's nothing but dreams
there's nothing but Vision there's
nothing but excitement
and if you're not careful how do they
select their first career choice
what their friends are doing that's
right I just got on down to factory come
on down there hiring right and that's
about how much work you they spend more
time picking out a suit of clothes than
they do a career that's right and you
can fall backwards into things if you
don't uh
deem yourself
of Great Value yeah and um you know if
you're in the technology world and you
actually know how to do technology uh
the sky's the limit yeah you're
incredibly on what you can do yeah but
you gotta actually believe it and I
can't get my foot in the door has
nothing to do with the technology world
has to do with his foot you nailed it
see here's what's going on with this
young man and a lot of people that are
listening today and watching if you
don't see how you are uniquely put
together then you will never believe
that you have tremendous value so this
is really a self-awareness situation but
I will tell you that undoubtedly and I
don't want to put him on the spot on the
air undoubtedly he has been in an
environment or he's had some experiences
that has made him feel as though he
doesn't have much to offer and so
awareness is huge to begin to see
himself as somebody who can do things
well that's talent who enjoys doing
things that's passion and who's
motivated by results that's a sense of
mission and that's what's in the
assessor that will give him so I want
the audience to know I didn't want to
put him on the spot I've talked to so
many people like that on the air that
they're dealing with a cloud of
confusion when you're in that you don't
interview well yeah you can't see
because anyone doing an interview looks
at that looks at that person that's
using that type of
lingo and sentence structure and they go
uh-uh yeah pretty quick it's almost as
big a turn off as the other end of the
spectrum where you get a guy if you
could buy him for what he's worth and
sell him for what he thinks he's worth
you'd be rich right you get a guy on the
other side who's all pumped up and you
know he really thinks he's something
he's not right yeah and that's the other
end of the spectrum and so when you're
when you're an employer or doing an
interview or an HR person doing a
recruiter doing an interview you're
picking up on these Vibes off of either
one of these two characters we're
talking about here and uh it makes a
difference quiet confidence and courage
is an amazingly powerful thing it
changes your voice tone it changes your
body language it changes your
um the believability that you can add
value to an organization this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today Melissa is with us in Rochester
New York hi Melissa welcome to the
Ramsey Show
Sharon thank you so much for having me
on the show sure what's up
sure so there was a lot I'm calling in
this because I'm having a couple of
issues right now I currently own the
home that I live in it is completely
paid off however that home is actually
my mom's home what was your mom's home
it's now yours
yes it was my mom's home it is in my
name now it is paid off however it was
originally my mom's home she lost it and
so I helped her save the home and now
it's in my name out of fear that she'll
lose it again
however sir my mom has made
infrastructure changes to the property
without this was before I even had the
home she had the infrastructure changes
and she didn't properly permit the house
so she's gone now a couple years with
having
rooms that she created into the house
that weren't permitted and so now I'm in
fear that I may be facing any type of
legal issues or ramifications that can
come out of a house being in my name and
her doing things to the home before they
were even in my name and so now I'm
trying to just save myself any issues
and they come out of all of this and I
want to just undate myself indeed my mom
back on the property and just give her
the property to take care of
how old is your mom
my mom is seven years old okay what did
she do to the house
she refinanced it no I'm talking about
the structural issues what did she
change
she added um bedrooms to the property
so she did an addition
yes it changed the square footage of the
house are they not within code well no
they had if you didn't permit and you
changed the square if she changed the
footprint right
yes so the actual outside structure of
the home is the same it was never
changed
built up additional walls creating
bedrooms inside inside the original
footprint inside the original footprint
correct yeah that's why I have no way of
knowing what happened there right
correct so no you're not having a lot
nothing to worry about there's nothing
to worry about
there's nothing to worry about right
nothing to worry about unless and that's
why I asked could she rewire the house
without getting an electrical permit
no did she replumb the house without
getting a plumbing permit
yes
completely replumbed the whole house
well she added a bathroom she had one
bathroom yeah okay
all right is it done is the construction
done
of reasonable quality
yes it is okay okay I don't think you
got a thing to worry about nothing at
all I think you got a thing to worry
about it would have been better to
permit it but lots of people do that
kind of stuff I mean that's a fairly
normal practice yeah some some
municipalities are much more strict than
others I can't tell you that you know
Rochester New York is not like the
toughest in the world or something I
don't know that but in general most
people you know it's inside the
footprint she didn't change the
dimensions of the house and um you know
she didn't illegally do a trade other
than adding a bath I I I really truly
um
I I don't think you got a thing to worry
about and I wouldn't give her the house
back because she's going to borrow
against it well here's what's gonna
happen is she's going to screw it up and
then she's going to try and leave it to
you and she dies
and you got to mess again you're gonna
get it back this thing's a boomerang
and now my one fear
it's about twenty thousand dollars the
driveway needs to be replaced fencing
needs to be added because she hasn't is
she living in it or are you
we're both living in it right now what
do you make a year
oh right now I'm not working I decided
to put myself back into school and I
just graduated two months ago how do you
people eat
um where's the money
well I have savings that I use up right
now I only have about 2 000 savings left
and you have a paid four houses all run
down
come again sir it's you have a paid for
house but it's all run down
yes it's run down yeah and what are you
getting ready to do for a career now
I'm getting ready to go into public
safety law enforcement to be specific
and you'll be making what
I'll be making approximately sixty
thousand dollars a year okay all right
well and I currently have okay I would
not date it back to her I would either
sell it to an investor as is and you
guys go about your Merry way or I would
sit there with a plan to to gradually do
the uh repairs that need to be done out
of cash from your new job
part of this is you want to get rid of
the of all the negative things that your
mom represents by getting rid of this
house
yes sir because right now she rents out
that's that's where some of the income
is coming and she did additional
bedrooms She rents out the bedrooms and
so that income she claims it all because
that's technically her retirement so she
doesn't work I'm sorry the house is
yours
how does she run out your house and she
collects the rent y'all are weird
yes
[Laughter]
only because the house was originally
mines I could save it from her I didn't
technically have any Financial
investment in it um how did you save it
I was able to
um when she short sold the house I was
able to purchase it for about forty
thousand dollars it's called a financial
investment
yes and she has Sunshine refunded me
that money
okay
um
you don't have boundaries
you know I I mean I think you might be
right Melissa actually I'm changing I'm
gonna change my mind right here in the
middle of this call wow I think you did
it to her and let her have it and you go
have a life
and when she passes away you auction it
off don't you ever move in it
okay I think this house and all the
chaos that occurs around your mother in
this house uh is all a huge negative
spot for you and a clean fresh start in
criminal justice system is a great thing
for you clean no chaos simple little one
bedroom apartment and you build up some
cash again and uh you've come out even
she gave you the money back that you use
to save the short sale but you can just
push all of this chaotic weirdness over
to the side and not have to worry about
it any more and just I would yeah I
would talk to a title company and I'd
deed it out of your name into hers and
you go move but only if there's a clean
break there yeah you have to you have to
you know what your own place you have to
have your life completely separate
completely clean all the chaos stays
over there on her side of the fence
don't help with the roof anything around
this mom figure is chaotic I can smell
it in the air she's a character
mom's a character and then you're
sitting there trying to be a normal
person in the middle of this character
and that's why I called y'all weird so
um I couldn't figure out how you own the
house and she's collecting the rent uh
but now I'm starting to understand so
yeah I think it is a good idea let's
just get away from it but not because of
the remodeling
uh because of the chaos around your mom
and this is never going to be it's
always going to be the weird part of
your life until you give it a little bit
of distance and a little bit of a
boundary all right Casey's in St
Petersburg Florida hi Casey what's up
hi thank you for taking my call sure how
can I help
um so I've just been listening listening
to your show for about a month now and I
um understand a little bit about the
baby steps and I actually just signed up
for the financial peace course through
my church wow great to get started on
that yeah
um so my situation is that I am 41
single I have 183
000 in student loan debt you're a doctor
or lawyer
uh nurse practitioner oh good that's
even better okay
so you're making what 110
.
um I'm making 135 135 great I love it
what are the debts have you got
have 8 000 in private student London
okay
um 5 000 in a parent plus loan for my
daughter
and I have this is the really hard part
to even say out loud is I have
um nineteen thousand dollars in credit
card debt from medical bills
um and other things okay what we're
gonna do is just do what we do in
Financial Peace University you're going
to live on beans and rice rice and beans
you make a wonderful income and as a
nurse practitioner you can also pick up
some side gigs called ER on the weekends
and it pays really well I want you
working all the time I want you spending
no money no restaurants no eating out no
vacations no life and now we're making
150 160 we're gonna live on about 40
we're gonna throw 100 at the student
loan debt and you're going to be 100
debt free in around two years but it's
going to be two years of hell so get
ready it'll be worth it though because
you'll be free that's exactly how you're
going to attack this with great focused
intensity good question I'm proud of you
get at it holler if you need some more
help
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
I'm Dave Ramsey thanks for joining us
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five Rebecca is in
Denver hi Rebecca welcome to the Ramsay
show
hi Dave thanks for taking
what's up
okay so my situation is I'm going
through a divorce
um my daughter and I are living in an
apartment and we're selling our house
and wondering
um on the other end of it I should have
between 100 and 125 000
from the equity I'm gonna beef up my
emergency fund and then
it could be cash for a cup for a custom
tiny house and my daughter is a senior
in high school
um
otherwise I'll probably stay in the
apartment for a few years trying to save
some more money just kind of was
wondering I know how you feel about
trailers I wasn't sure if it was the
same with the tiny houses yeah what's
your uh income
uh 85
and um how long were you married
seven years I'm sorry
it's a hard thing to go through
um yeah well here's the problem with the
tiny house
um
other than the fact that it's tiny
here's the problem with the tiny house
uh there is no track record out there
it's a fairly new phenomenon and there's
no track record out there that says that
there's a secondary market for it
meaning when you get ready to sell it
there's no evidence in the marketplace
yet that you're going to be able to sell
it at all
and that you'll be able to sell it um uh
for a price even close to what you paid
for it
so you could get really stuck
um if they you know you know so why is
it I don't like mobile homes well
there's a long track record they go down
in value a hundred percent of the time
okay so we have a pattern an observable
pattern
and in finance things that's what you're
looking for is an observable pattern and
so it's why you would like for instance
if you bought a home in a neighborhood
uh that is way out on the edge of town
and is brand new that's not as
predictable an environment as buying a
home in a tree-lined street that has
been there for 20 years and is very
predictable you follow me so yes even
those two neighborhoods those are both
single-family homes I'm discussing there
but those two neighborhoods give you a
predictable pattern and that's why I
would never buy a tiny home because it's
such a new phenomenon we don't know
what's going to happen and and we do
know this we do know this the market
is uh is nowhere near the per the number
of people looking for a tiny home at a
given moment would be
way smaller than the number of people
looking for a regular home agreed
yes so your your opportunity to your
your buyer pool that you would sell to
is very small no pun intended so
not physically small but numbers small
but the uh there's a lot of tiny home
jokes here but yeah the uh yeah so I I
yeah no I would not buy one for that
reason it's that simple it's not that I
hate on them or something like that I do
hate the
this idea that they're presented out
there is somehow the answer to
High house prices the answer to this or
that they're not the answer you know not
yet
someday there may be a robust Market of
people buying other people's tiny homes
uh but today there's not and so no I
would tell you don't do that I would run
an apartment for a little while I don't
think it's going to be five years I I
think you can go buy a home you have a
good income you got a hundred thousand
bucks to put down so get you a good
15-year fix you know Denver's an
expensive Market it's tough to buy there
but I would not give up on real estate
for five years so you kind of presented
me three options I'm gonna be in an
apartment I'm gonna buy a tiny home or
I'm gonna be an apartment and wait five
years or two options uh and I think
you're an apartment a lot less than five
years
um but part of this is you guys getting
your
your spirits and your emotions reset
after this
pain that you two have been through you
and your daughter and uh just having a
simple apartment situation is a not a
bad thing for a year and just use that
year to live very conservatively and add
to the hundred thousand dollar down
payment and then talk about maybe this
time next year you're talking about
buying a home and you know it's a
presidential election year maybe we'll
see interest rates come down who knows
other than the fact that they almost
always do during a presidential election
because it's hard to get elected you
pretty much give up the White House if
you give up the economy so we kind of
got that coming right there is that and
I you know I also think just with all
the pain and Trauma that they're going
through that high school senior daughter
needs some space and you're in a tiny
home there's no space and her having her
own you know place to move around that
Senior Year let you guys heal and get
stable I think this comes from a lot of
people feel like uh renting is throwing
money away and it's not when we're
getting stable it's not when it's
patience with a plan yes yeah spoke
looking like a dad of teenagers okay yes
Mary is in Washington D.C hi Mary how
are you
doing okay how are you guys doing better
than we deserve how can we help
yeah I was calling and my husband and I
have just started following your program
um and you know we've made some some I
think smart decisions over the years but
we've been doing things in the different
in in uh not necessarily the order that
you guys have laid out and so I wanted
to call in and check to see
um sort of a a challenging question the
moral question is should we pull back on
things like typing
or retirement in the short term to focus
on debt it feels odd to do that
um but I know that it's a hunk of money
so I don't know we're just calling to
get get your thoughts and advice on that
okay uh we never tell people to pull
back on their tithe
and tithe is off the top it's first
fruits it says in Proverbs many times
and so it's the first thing you do so if
you're a person of Faith which is what
what you're indicating by saying tithe
because that's that's a a word
associated with our faith
um so judeo-christian ethic of some kind
of you know whether you're Christian or
Jewish either one but that's where the
word tithe comes from so you're putting
that up front now the rest of it is
um the most powerful wealth building
tool you have is your income
and when you give it to someone else in
the form of debt payments you slow down
your ability to build wealth so how old
are you guys
um 40 41. okay and how much debt do you
have not counting your home
about 60 000 on what
um 58 of it is um student loans left on
a car and um what's your household
income
about 110 okay and how much do you have
in retirement now
um we each have maybe between 80 and 100
so if you have any money that's not in
retirement
uh we have a little bit in savings
five thousand dollars okay you don't
have another mutual fund sitting around
or another investment account or
anything else
no no it's all sort of wrapped up in
retirement gotcha okay so what we would
tell you to do and we think this is the
short we know we've proven this is the
shortest path to wealth versus the one
you're on is uh we would continue our
charitable giving continue tithing off
the top before you do anything be on a
detailed written Budget on the every
dollar app the two of you are in
agreement on what we're doing I would
temporarily
stop the retirement savings and I would
clean up this debt in the next 12 to 18
months and then you don't have any
payments but a house payment but this
student loan is going to hang around so
long you think it's a freaking pet
yeah it's been around for you know 15
plus years now oh it's a fat pad okay
yeah this thing Sallie Mae's got Sallie
Mae's gotten to be a toxic bother she
needs to go oh my gosh yes yes and we've
gotten it down I mean no you hadn't you
still owe 58 don't tell me you guys
fifty eight thousand dollars you need to
attack this with complete focus and
temporarily for a short period of time
year to a year and a half I'd stop my
retirement and I would attack that with
a vengeance
like my hair was on fire
and if you do that I mean you put 30 000
a year on it you'll be done in two years
you put sixty thousand a year on it
you're done in one year so somewhere
between those two is probably where
you're gonna land and I'd really dial it
up and get after it kiddo
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today
our last caller 40 years old with a
student loan that's been around forever
still hanging out with a student loan at
40. 58 000 student loan and of course we
are most of us aware anyway that student
loan interest restarted September 1 and
the payments will start in a couple of
weeks here again in October
so we've got
um
somewhere around 44 million Americans
with 1.7 trillion dollars in debt that
have this train barreling down the
tracks at you so we decided to help out
because the name of our company is
Ramsey Solutions so we need to give some
solutions not just um not just squawking
about it so we're going to do that
tonight if you want to join us 7 p.m
tonight Tuesday night September the 12th
we are doing a live stream it's
completely free it is me Jade warshaw
and Rachel Cruz we're going to be
talking about
student loan debt in America how we got
here and how we're going to get out uh
it'll be in four or five hours from
right now if you're listening to us live
but it is a 7 PM Central Time
Tuesday night September the 12th it's
free just go to ramseysolutions.com
student loans and you can put in your
email address and you'll be able to give
the live stream a free watch we'll send
you the link pretty simple Patricia is
up next in Roanoke Virginia hi Patricia
how are you
good thank you I have a question about
my auto
okay
so my question is my lease is coming up
um I went to the dealership and the
amount to buy it out is twenty seven
thousand dollars now
um I don't know if I should just go
ahead and buy the car or get a cheaper
car
and and we just kind of like debt free
because I will still have the mortgage
do you have any money
uh I do have a savings of thirty
thousand dollars okay
um
what is the car worth
uh 28 000 so a thousand dollars over the
price yeah so it's no bargain
it's an okay deal but you probably get
that deal on a used car lot
so there's there's nothing that says to
buy this car if you were sitting with um
no car right now and you told me you had
thirty thousand dollars I would not tell
you to buy a 28 000 car
because you only have thirty thousand
dollars that would be using up all of
your money you see what I'm saying yeah
so I'm gonna toss them the keys when
this lease is up and go buy you about a
ten thousand dollar car what do you make
a year
uh it depends but the minimum 55 000 it
depends how much I work to be honest
yeah yeah well the maximum car you ought
to buy would be uh 50 of your income
so that puts you at about you know
twenty five thousand bucks but that's
too much car because you don't have the
money so if I woke up in your shoes I
would have no car payment and be driving
a very nice gently experienced ten
thousand dollar car now the difference
in a ten thousand dollar car and a
thirty thousand dollar car is pretty
substantial
but it's not it's not like it's
unreliable it's not like it's not safe
it's not like it's any of those things
what is unreliable is being broke what
is unsafe is being broke
and two thousand dollars with a thirty
thousand dollar car when you make sixty
five thousand is broke
I wouldn't put you there so I wouldn't
buy that car and I wouldn't buy anything
anywhere near that price
uh now if you told me you had a hundred
thousand in savings yeah and you love
this car maybe but uh even then it's a
lot of car for someone with your income
a lot a lot of money tied up
yeah I I've been shopping Dave you know
this for teenagers you can get really
decent cars uh in the 10 to 12 000 range
even in this so-called you know used car
inflationary period you can do it you
just have to swallow your pride and go
wait a second I'd rather have more money
than so-called pride and you can get
really decent cars that are functional
and still in good shape it's very doable
I look all the time I got two more to
buy next year I'm a used car expert day
at least I'm self-proclaimed you know
but I mean that's reality well you're
finding stuff out there that's safe yes
it's got a lot of life left in it yes
it's not filthy it's trash I mean
fifteen thousand dollar car is not a
hoopty no you know that's a nice car I
just got my son Ty at a Ford Explorer
2012 Ford Explorer just give you an
example twelve thousand dollars bought
it from a nice local businessman had it
in his it's HVAC if I said the name
you'd know him and it was sitting in
their parking lot they've treated it
wonderfully it's in phenomenal shape his
eyes about bugged out of his head and
I'm mine too I didn't expect to get into
something that nice at that price range
but uh it's a fantastic car barely over
a hundred thousand miles wow so I mean
this is not a lot of years this isn't
fantasy I'm not just saying this it's
doable yeah that's what we would do in
your shoes Kennedy is in Indianapolis hi
Kennedy how are you
I'm good how are you better than I
deserve what's up
um okay so this is actually for Ken
um more so so I applied for I'm
I'm in a position I've been in it for a
year and a half I meet all the
qualifications to get promoted to a
senior position per the guidelines that
my job laid out the only thing I'm
missing is the year and a half of in the
same position I've worked for the
company for almost five years come
February but I've been in this position
for a year and a half they want me to be
in it for three but I have all the other
qualifications and they're like we're
sorry we can't do anything because you
don't have the extra year and a half so
you just have to sit there for a year
and a half before we will promote you
I don't know how to get around that I'm
doing everything extra I listened to you
a couple days ago and you're like you
know just I asked my boss hey I want to
be promoted I want to be a manager this
is what I want to do what do I have to
do to get it and she said you've got to
wait a year and a half yeah so anything
I can do no
you have to decide do you want to be
there do you want to work because they
have laid out for you what is required
and you know listen this is this is the
tension between patients and persistence
you know we want to move forward we want
progress but it requires patience and so
now they've laid it out very clearly for
in fact I'll be honest with you I'm
really impressed that they held the line
on what they prefer not they sound like
a bunch of idiot bureaucrats well then
there's Dave's opinion I mean really I
mean I'll tell you the woman's been
there five years she'd be promoted at
Ramsay
well but we don't if anything about the
organization she meets all the other
qualifications the only thing she hadn't
done is sit on her butt in that one role
for a year and a half all right so let
me clarify well I don't necessarily have
to agree with it I respect the fact that
they were clear and they've held a lot
more consistent so the point is they
communicated clearly to you is what I
was saying and I respect which gives you
the opportunity to leave so now you get
to decide do you want to wait another
year and a half or do you want to move
on
so so here's the ultimate if you knew
that they changed their mind today would
you be super excited about the present
and the future with this guy well then I
love it I love the company it's just I I
don't want to be stuck in the same all I
am I want to get promoted I feel like I
deserve to get promoted because I have
all right let me ask you something all
right let me ask you this yeah do you
agree with Dave that they're uh that
they're uh it's a requirement is it
arbitrary or do they tie it to actual
hours I don't even know what you do is
it arbitrary or is it legit
that they require three years of
experience
so in their requirement they have eight
different sections and you have to meet
about 50 50 in either of those sections
and then the requirement is minimum of
three years in the same position doing
the same role and I have that from like
outside experience but not three years
with this company so not three years
with them okay I get it all right I get
what David's saying but she's been there
five years yeah I think you should get
that I've been with them for five years
yeah listen I agree with Dave you should
get the gig but I at least appreciate
they've told you so now you got to deal
with it I don't think you being the
squeaky wheel is going to change their
policy some people in some companies
like policy more than this big company
too of course yes guaranteed yeah it's a
it's a policy over principle more rules
than a sense that's all they do they
don't think well wait a second this
lady's got this experience outside of
here she more than meets the required
that's not the way they think so you got
to decide do I want to be here and deal
with the way they think or do I want to
move on unfortunately that's what you're
left with yeah great great I mean they
do have the right to do that it's their
right they own it yeah and you know
sometimes people don't agree with stuff
I do here and it's got my name on the
building though I do whatever I want to
do that's right you don't have to agree
with it but and then sometimes they
leave because they don't agree with it
and that's an option that's an option
too
Yep this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsey Baby Steps
go to ramsesolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsay show
where we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships thank you for
joining us America I'm Dave Ramsey your
host Kent Coleman Ramsay personality
host of the Ken Coleman show and author
of the number one selling book from
paycheck to purpose where he helps
people with their careers their jobs and
their work and he's going to be doing
that today right here on the Ramsey Show
phone number here is triple eight eight
two five five two two five Louisa is
with us in Washington D.C hi Louisa how
are you
good afternoon so great to be speaking
with you today thank you so much for
taking my call thank you what's up
all right I've got a what would they do
scenario and I'm pretty sure I know what
you're going to say but I kind of just
want to walk through some options I have
and it's concerning my mortgage so a
little bit of background
um I have an arm that resets every
November and
um it hasn't really been you know much
of an issue until recently obviously
because the rates have gone up so it is
resetting from four and a half to six
and a half percent joyful
um yep the balance on the loan is 99
000. I've actually paid off 52 000 in
the last year and I am on track to pay
this off my goal is December of 2025.
okay
so here are the scenarios I just want to
walk through want to get your thought
um option one is just to you know stick
with you know stick with the the new
payment coming up in November
um my payment is actually going down 180
even with the rate going up because I
pay off so much so it's actually going
down
um 180 so that's option one is just
proceeding with you know six and a half
percent
um and then you know with the right
would reset you know next year
option two is a recast and I've kind of
read where you're not a big fan of a
mortgage recast
um and want to get your thoughts on
those so obviously the rate would stay
the same six and a half percent
um this would require a twenty thousand
dollar payment
um by the end of October and that would
lower the payment a hundred and forty
dollars a month okay
so that's option two and then why would
you want to lower it if you're paying it
off in two years what's the benefit
that's where I
I don't understand it's like we're
trying to pay it off in two years or two
and a half years right right so how does
lowering the payment accomplish that
um I mean it's lowering the interest
that I'm paying no it's not I mean that
would be no it's not
um if you recap you're going to recast
at a lower interest rate
well I'm recasting I'm taking it from a
balance of 99 000. oh it would lower the
balance
but you could do that anyway you don't
have to do Recaps to do that
yes I could and that's what I've been
doing is just recast all recasting does
is reset the payment based on a longer
term it doesn't change the interest
charged right right okay so there's no
benefit to you mathematically to recast
okay given that you're planning to pay
it off in two years
and here's the other thing that I I
don't have
sitting around well then there's that
right exactly so that kind of brings me
to option three
um and let me let me just preface this
by saying I heard you about a year and a
half ago maybe two years ago before the
rates you know were creeping up
because I was going to re refinance and
I remember you telling a caller don't
refinance if you can pay it off in three
years so I kind of went with that model
and I'm I'm on I'm on target I'm on
track to pay this off and that's that is
really why I did not refinance um but
option three would be digging into my
brokerage account and paying it off
entirely I have I have about two hundred
thousand dollars I'd have to cash you
know not in a retirement you have a
brokerage account sitting there with
enough to pay it off
I do pay it off today
you knew I was going to do that
I I did I did I still wanted to walk
through the options okay so if if you
had a paid for a home
with a brokerage account with a hundred
thousand dollars Less in it would you go
borrow ninety nine thousand dollars on
your home paid for home to put more
money in your brokerage account
no it's the same thing
yeah yeah I think I think I'm just
having some
let me tell you what's going to happen
all right that you don't anticipate
because I've been the other side of it
myself and with a whole bunch of other
people
you do not understand when you pay this
off
and you walk out in the backyard with no
shoes on that the grass is going to feel
so much different there's going to be a
level of Peace blow through your home
like a nice cool wind that you don't
even know is coming
when you own no man nothing
all this hand-wringing you've been doing
for the last few minutes trying to
figure out what to do all that's gone
just clean and simple
you just own your house
you're weird I love it
I love it
and listen if you really hate it then go
get your new mortgage
yeah but I don't think you're gonna hate
it I think you're going to feel freedom
that you have not felt in your adult
life
yep
and I know that from the having
experienced it myself because I don't
have any dad and haven't had for 30
years and I walk around without all of
these weights on my shoulders
and um that a lot of people have and I
get to make different decisions and have
a different level of calm in the middle
of a storm and all of that pay off your
house Louisa please
I promise you you won't regret it but if
I'm completely Bonkers and you do regret
it you can always go get you another
mortgage
and theoretically put it back in the
brokerage there's a fear there you can
hear it yeah no it's just this angst of
the devil I know yeah that's right the
devil I know versus the peace I've never
known and
um it's I don't know if I'm doing
something wrong I don't know if which is
the correct thing and let me just tell
you man once you get no
payments in the whole freaking world
Financial Peace
two words that don't go together like
Airline service man
like Postal Service sorry to you postal
people oh my gosh sorry to you Airline
people I mean really I mean it's
Financial Peace two words that don't go
together I mean I've got money in a
brokerage I've got my emergency fund
I've got retirement going and I own my
whole freaking house
somebody you need to breathe that in
make that a goal um
some of you spend a lot of calories
flipping stuff over in your head ringing
your hands trying to figure out
something
when the answers are usually pretty
simple clean it up people
simplify simplify
that's it simplify
yeah huh it's hard to beat guys hard to
beat this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow Halo is the number
one Prayer app in the world and they're
giving you three months free to get
started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow is
like you can tailor the content towards
your faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hollow.com Ramsay today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today
our question of the day for the Ramsey
show is sponsored by neighborly your hub
for home services for repairs and
maintenance to Remodeling and upgrades
neighborly's trusted home service
providers have trained local experts who
can handle almost any job so go to
neighborly.com to find and schedule
service today today's question comes
from Roger in South Carolina I'm a 20
year old male currently studying
aerospace engineering I know the
Aerospace industry is very cyclical so I
was wondering if having a one-year
salary emergency fund would be a good
idea before having kids
well I'm sitting next to the guy who uh
created the concept I I don't think a
year is necessary and and I don't know
enough to understand why he believes the
Aerospace industry is so cyclical but
six months uh if you're in kind of a a
topsy-turvy industry like that I think
would be good I don't hate having a
one-year Mercy fund but is it necessary
no with Roger Roger you're an engineer
you over analyze things
your job is to perceive risk and so you
see risk everywhere but there's not that
much risk you will be fine if you have
an aerospace engineering degree you will
be able to get a job and feed your
family sometime in the six month period
yeah six months is fine but um and
here's the other thing the more money
you put into that the slower you build
wealth
the faster you build wealth the less you
worry about an emergency fund if you got
a million dollars in a mutual fund and
five thousand dollars in mutual in an
emergency fund you don't have enough in
your emergency fund but you got a
million dollars in a mutual fund so
you're gonna be okay yeah you know it's
so the faster you build wealth the less
you have to worry about any of this so
you're going to be just fine Tom's in St
Paul Minnesota hi Tom welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey Dave and Ken I just wanted to say
starting off your principles have you
know changed my my wife's life and my
life so just wanted to thank you guys
for your ministry thank you
yeah um so so uh so getting to my
question a little bit of context
um last month I actually called Ken uh
called Ken on his show and I was just
laid off from my mortgage loan officer
job actually working at Wells Fargo and
I was looking for places to basically
trying to figure out references and Ken
gave me great advice and a month later I
now have a job at a Toyota dealership
um selling cars so really exciting uh I
guess my main question is
is a lot of people are coming in they're
financing their car uh they're leasing
their cars in fact you know there's some
incentive for us to push Leaf is just
because from our standpoint you know
that creates repeat customers now none
of this stuff is stuff that I would
recommend to my loved ones I would never
do it myself
um is there am I in the wrong if I'm in
a position where I'm where I'm sometimes
selling these uh if so should I consider
changing jobs or what what are your
thoughts well I don't you're not
ethically doing anything wrong this is
not any legal activity but because you
don't believe in it we don't believe in
it either but this is about your
principles eventually this is going to
eat away at you so short term uh I I
would be looking for something to make a
transition because long term this will
eat away at you and listen you know I
talk about engagement all the time I
study the data listen a person who
doesn't believe in the mission the
product the service of a company is not
going to be fully engaged and that has a
lot of negative effects finding
Financial opportunities for you
promotional opportunities it affects
your health your mental health and
Beyond so I think long term if I'm a guy
like you that has a strong principle
conviction that you have I would
eventually move on from selling
something that you just don't believe in
yeah it's it's not something you have to
run out of the building today like your
hair is on fire like you discovered the
boss had 20 pounds of cocaine in his
office you don't you don't hang out
there another day okay that's not what's
going on this is uh you know
a disagreement of how the product works
and so uh Rabbi Lapin talks about the in
his book He's my good friend Orthodox
Jewish rabbi and he wrote a book called
thou shall prosper and
um the book is the ten reasons that
Jewish people have had an inordinate
probability of see being financially
successful in any point in human history
they tend to thrive and why is that one
of the things is they believe that
making money is an honorable thing if
you're doing an honorable thing and uh
one of the things he points out in that
chapter it's one of the ten things is
that it's if you're doing something
that's psychologically
incompatible with your belief system
it's very difficult to be good at it
and so you know back that's another way
of saying exactly what Ken said and so
yeah I'm completely aligned with what
Coleman is saying here if I were in your
shoes I would say I'm going to give
myself 60 days and I'm going to be
somewhere else
because they're they're the they are
going to sell car leases because they
make more money on cart not because of
repeat customers but because they make
more money on car leases than they do on
the actual sale of the car and they make
more money on car leases than they do if
they do a regular Finance plan with a
bank and they make more money on car
leashes than they do just about anything
else
it's the one of the most profitable
parts of the entire Auto industry now
and so it's massively profitable for
them this paper is amazing and so
they're they're not only going not going
to not stop it they're going to push it
because it's where they make their money
and so that's how it is it's like
there's a series of Articles have gone
around the last few years that if you
work at Victoria's Secret selling uh
small underwear right
you you have to sell a certain number of
Victoria's Secret credit cards or they
will not give you hours okay
because they're in more in the credit
card business than they are the small
underwear business right small underwear
is there just to get you into the credit
card debt interest in the big debt small
underwear big debt there it is so there
you go that's a great slogan
yeah that's uh so but if you if you want
to work there in that store in the
retail store uh you're not gonna get
hours that's right you're not going to
be promoted if you don't sell credit
cards even if you sell a whole bunch of
small underwear and you don't sell any
credit cards you're going to be on the
street they you know but that's the
business they're in they know where
their money's coming from they know what
the profit centers are and they're going
to drive you that way so then you've got
to decide as an employee are you going
to plug into that and I think you've
already decided sure Tom yeah I think
he's already on he had already decided
and just wants permission is this silly
no it's unsilly at all no it's smart
Brian is in Jacksonville Florida hey
Brian welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave how you doing today better than
I deserve what's up I'm glad to hear it
um I had a question for you um I'll give
you a little background information on
myself um I'm 40 year old I have two
kids my wife's a stay-at-home mom we own
a town home we owe about 55 000 left on
it my wife has some savings around 60k
and I'm debating whether I should use
that money to pay at the house
or if I should invest it like in an IRA
or something for the future but the
thing is we're in a small town home and
we're looking to get something a little
bit more a little bit more space for you
know for the family because kids are
sharing a room I got a boy and a girl
when are you winning awesome we're not
moving at all yeah we just we like to
get another property because we like to
have I mean it's just like two years or
a year or 10 minutes
oh it's probably the next couple years
probably three years pay it off
today okay today the reason I ask is my
financial advisor tells me not to
because he says my interest rate in my
home is going to be less than what I'd
be making on the stock market that's
what I figured out guess what guess what
he didn't make a dime when you pay off
the house he makes commission when you
invest the money with him
I understand that
hello ding ding ding ding and I didn't
make a dime either way
so you do whatever you want to do but if
I woke up in your shoes I'd have a paid
for house now you need to get yourself
on a budget and you need to sit down
with another financial advisor that's
not giving you stupid butt advice and
get you an IRA started and get your kids
for it get your kids 529 started and
let's get some investing going and get
yourself on a budget with your wife and
the two of you working together let's
get detailed and dial this money stuff
in man because it kind of feels like
you're loosey-goosey running out here
just for trying to figure this out as
you go and you need to dial it in and
make sure every dollar is barking every
dollar is doing what it's supposed to do
so getting the every dollar app getting
Financial Peace University do that kind
of stuff but uh if I woke up in your
shoes I'd pay my house off today dude
just like that no question
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us America
if you like what you hear around here
you could help us out and we'd
appreciate it click the follow button
the Subscribe button the share button
share the show share a link tell people
where you're listening on talk radio or
TBN or whatever it is
spread the word about the show and leave
a five star review they're very helpful
all of those things the share the like
the uh subscribe the follow all of those
things will really push the show to the
front of the algorithms and cause people
to find us and it doesn't cost you a
thing and we would appreciate the help
thank you very much Trevor is in Salt
Lake City hi Trevor welcome to the
Ramsey Show
thanks for having me Dave I really
appreciate it
um I grew up watching grew up listening
to your show with my parents so huge fan
of yours well thank you um I got a
question I got a question for you
um regarding
um either reinvesting in my business or
purchasing a home and I can give you a
little bit of information about it so
I'm 23 years old I'm getting married in
a week wow and I thank you and for you
congratulations
thank you
um between me and my fiance we have
about fifty thousand dollars in our
savings account uh we have no debt
um my business has about 75 000 in
assets
um as well as I have about twenty five
thousand dollars in Investments mutual
funds CDs stuff like that
um and I'm just wondering with your
expert opinion what I should do if I
should reinvest in my business to
continue to grow it or whether or not I
should look into purchasing a home how
much do you need to reinvest on the
business and why
so the reason
my business I just bought a new skidster
I do landscaping
um I've been able to pay everything
trash trailers equipment
um I just got a new Skid Steer and I'm
looking to purchase a second truck
um I have three employees I'm looking to
have a second truck for the band as well
as a new trailer and just upgrading some
of our mowing equipment and stuff like
that
okay if you spend that money you're
gonna spend
what twenty thirty thousand bucks
correct and what does that cause you to
make because you spent that that you
wouldn't make if you didn't recommend it
okay so this uh I'm anticipating this
year to make about eighty thousand
um that's after uh taxes everything
um and I'm anticipating if I can get
that reinvestment I can make an
additional 20 to 30.
um so you can make the money back in a
year next year
um yes probably spend 20 or 30 and make
an extra 20 or 30 as a result
correct okay
and sounds like you got 75 000.
um correct and that's in equipment and
you make uh no no you're 75 000 cash you
have 25 in a mutual fund of 50 in your
account right
uh yeah approximately all right and uh
what does your wife make
um she makes about 40 a year
and you're gonna net on your business a
hundred
uh no I'm anticipating 80 this year I
reinvested quite a bit this year I just
bought the skid steer about two weeks
ago
um so that ran me a little bit and I do
owe um the only debt I have is I'll my
father who
um was gifted me 15 000 towards my skid
steer I bought so I'm gonna pay him back
oh is that a gift or a loan
uh alone more or less
well that's an interesting piece of
information for a guy for 10 minutes has
been telling me he was debt free you're
not debt free you owe your dad 15 grand
no you're not going to invest in your
business you're going to be paying your
dad back
I'm I will pay it off in the next month
I don't know today you have the money in
your account right now you shouldn't
have taken it from him in the first
place
okay you got 50 000 bucks you need to
borrow 15 000 from your dad
correct I just wanted to keep some money
in an emergency fund where where I am
self-employed I just and getting married
I wanted to be allowed for money yeah
that way
if you needed the money if you need the
money for an emergency fund you
shouldn't have bought a skid steer but
you bought one now and now you got a
loan and now you got to pay it off I'd
pay that off today
um and then what I would do is get
married and spend the first year of your
marriage piling up cash for a good down
payment on a house and after you've been
married a year you will make a different
purchase than after you've been married
a week
it's a different house it takes a year
of being married to know how close to
your mother-in-law or your father-in-law
who loans you money for skid steers that
you want to live
how close do you want to live with these
people yeah it takes a year to figure
that out
so um it's a joke but not really yeah I
was gonna say a lot of truth of that the
other thing too is that I would be
challenging myself how can I make an
additional fifteen twenty thousand
dollars a year over the next year of my
business without spending 20 to 30. you
know get Innovative uh and especially in
that first year of marriage he was
already worried that's why I took the
loan out from his dad I believe yeah
so Trevor you need to quit buying toys
for your business that you haven't done
a careful Roi on because you're not
going to get an Roi on this skid steer
that's bullcrap you're not going to make
enough on that thing to justify having
purchased it you would have made you
would have been better off buying mowing
equipment to expand your operation than
with a skid steer so quit buying
business toys
that don't have very fast large Roi
stop it
not a friend of mine that's in the
building business and he bought a skid
steer
now I bought a skid steer the other day
too did you really yeah there's one out
at the farm for you I bought it for no
reason at all except I have the money
it's a toy you like moving dirt well I
got my grandson in my lap digging up
stuff that doesn't even need to be dug
up all right so this is embarrassing
this won't surprise Dave at all but you
guys are throwing skid steer around skid
steer this is I had to Google it real
quick James a bobcat it's a bobcat I
that I would have known it's a bobcat on
tracks it's pretty cool looking little
machine it's on tracks it's a skid steer
right so basically you papa Dave got his
own real life Tonka it's a toy yeah
that's exactly what it is it is it's
great and good for you yeah it's fun
because your grandson thinks that's
really cool oh my God it's a giant
there's no cooler Papa Dave in the world
than one with a skid steer so what I'm
hearing is live like no one else so
later you can dig holes for no reason at
all
yes to make your grandson happy that's
the dream of every grandfather hey every
four-year-old's dug a hole for no
apparent reason and every 64 year old
apparently is going to do the same thing
never get over it I was going to say no
one else so the public knows I'm not
anti-skidsteer okay I'm just saying but
from a business perspective
don't buy stuff that you can't Roi
quickly every and I gotta tell you
here's an interesting thing working with
uh people on entree leadership
very few women do this in business
it's kind of a male thing yeah it's a
male stupid thing it's toys and they do
it they do it with com they do it with
computers right the guys that do all
this equipment stuff in here I have to
constantly go no we don't need another
one all right good God how many
microphones do I need to own seriously
that's good boys collect toys man
there's just something about it and I I
ladies they they're very careful but
oftentimes I have to get them to go the
other way it's hard to get them to do
the actual investment they need to do
right to to because they're conservative
on it but very few women in business
collect toys like boys do and you know
what's interesting I'll bet you can
prove this they're much more resourceful
as well think about the mom who always
makes the science project happen under
the wire you know with a couple straws
you know a rubber band here it's like
you can build that business that
landscaping business without that new
truck you can't you just got to be
Innovative and that's where Innovation
comes from is when we have a lack of
resources Craig grossel talks about that
a lot yeah in fact he he's the one that
it was mind-blowing I think I
interviewed him years ago when I was
hosted on trail leadership it's one of
the best thoughts on Innovation that
I've ever heard is from Craig Rochelle
yeah it created a lack create a lack of
necessity yeah to become creative on how
you're gonna do it if you can't do it
any other way yeah and so that's why
your dad did you no favor loaning you
that money right so that's the thing so
all that to pick on you Trevor because
we love you and we want you to win so
pay off your dad today uh get a little
apartment and uh shut up house and
concentrate on loving each other not on
stupid real estate deals for the first
year of your marriage and after you've
been married a year and saved up a
little more money above your emergency
fund and you're truly debt free and the
next time you tell somebody you're dead
free make sure you are
uh then
uh then from there you pay you put down
with a good strong down payment on a
15-year fixed after you've been married
a year
that's what I would do if I were in your
shoes congratulations on the marriage
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
whether one
guarantee and shipping is always free
see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40 percent off everything site-wide go
to blinds.com for more information
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thanks for hanging out with us
America this is the Ramsay show we're so
glad you're here
hey guys uh George camel and the every
dollar team are hosting a free live
virtual training
for your budget yeah you're gonna learn
how to find more margin in your finances
to spend without guilt and to make a
budget that actually works first one is
happening September the 19th at 12 30
Eastern Time spots are limited you can
pick one with George Jade warshaw is
going to be doing some I think Rachel
Cruz might be doing another one too so
all these budgeting webinars are
completely free go to everydollar.com
budgeting and we'll help you get started
with this stuff all right here we go
Josh is in Orlando hi Josh welcome to
the Ramsay show
hey never grow up especially if you can
afford it right gentlemen
that's right there's the plan what's up
man
okay so I have a pro and a console
here's my dilemma and I'm actually so
I'm trying to get as get free as I
possibly can I have uh 17 no about 19 20
000 in credit card debt and then that's
my primary and then my secondary is my
auto loan which I'm about 11 000 upside
down
um in regards to my credit card
um I have
18 000 in RSU uh shares for my company
and then I have seven thousand dollars
and a traditional IRA
wanting to know if I should uh use my
stock to my use I want to know if I can
use both if you have my credit card debt
I would not use an IRA I would use your
stock
okay and the reason for not using the
IRA penalties taxes okay leave those
alone and I would quit adding to the IRA
and I would cut up the credit cards and
never touch the stupid things again get
a debit card do not even own a credit
card
okay 100 100 and then what about the ra
to where I
cast it out I have it in a savings
account you already have
yeah uh well I did I did a transfer or I
did the the part of the work that I
haven't fully transferred it to my
personal savings account
when did you do this
I did it last Friday to where it was
effective for me to utilize today
okay uh well you've got 60 days to undo
it without penalty and so I'm gonna get
go to ramsesolutions.com and click on
smartvester and find a smart vister Pro
in the area to help you undo it and get
it back into an IRA before you get hit
with the penalties and the taxes how
much was in that you said there's only
like seven thousand in the account
though right yeah it was only seven yeah
so you're probably only going to lose
three or four thousand bucks but that's
still a ridiculous I mean you're paying
40 interest effectively to get the money
freed up I would not do that I think
it's a good practice for you to learn to
leave that alone so let's roll that back
into while you're in the 60-day window
back you know get you an IRA set up with
a with a smartvestor pro and um
then start your
um
I'm sorry then cut up your credit cards
and pay them all off and then you've
still got to clean up your auto loan
that's your next thing so beans and rice
rice and beans no adding to any
Investments of any kind and we're
completely focused on clearing this debt
that's the next process there so good
question open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Tyler
is in Jacksonville Florida hi Tyler
welcome to the Ramsay show
better than I deserve what's up
yeah so I got a a little bit of a
dilemma here with uh some in-laws I
guess give you a back story on married
uh moved away from home and uh I guess I
said in-laws but my my parents uh
moved away from home and you know
they're my mother's not in a great
financial situation she
hasn't been working
um and has some tax issues from a past
business and she's asking to borrow some
money to make a house payment and um you
know I feel led to but I'm also trying
to
talk to her in in the nicest way
possible to try to sort out a longer
term plan than you know make a payment
and then what do we do next month and
what do we do next month uh my siblings
uh Arnez financially capable to help so
I feel like how old are you Tyler
what was that how old are you
uh 28. how old's your mother
um
57.
okay
on what planet is the 28 year old
supposed to take care of the 57 year old
that was too trifling to do it herself
it's not your job man it's not your job
yep and I bet your wife isn't happy with
this either
no what do you make a year
um combined we're making probably
250 260. you're making bank aren't you
good for you okay what is your mom doing
nothing
calling Tyler for money it's not working
at all
no no not currently uh well take me back
when when was she working
um it's been a while
um
housing housing company
quite a while ago and why is she not
working
um
not a there's not a good reason I don't
think so either okay so you're giving
her money is not sustainable because you
were correct in your wisdom When You
observe that you're going to be doing it
again next month the next month the next
month the next month because you're
enabling her bad behavior yeah instead
what I would do is come alongside her
and say Mom
I'm going to be your biggest cheerleader
I'm going to give you some suggestions
and some help and show you what to do so
you can straighten this out first thing
we're going to do is we're going to get
into Ken Coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose and we're going to get you a job
and a career and then I'm going to put
you on to every dollar on a budget and
you're going to make money and pay your
own bills and you're going to like
yourself more when you do that I am not
going to pay your bills mom but I will
be here for you I love you and I will
help you figure out a way to pay your
bills
and she's not going to like that Tyler
because she likes doing nothing
yeah yeah I think that could be the case
yeah she's going to get angry with you
and she's going to become a travel agent
with for guilt trips which is what
codependent people do when their enabler
Cuts them off
yeah yeah I'm sorry this is going to be
tough but you're being very wise I'm not
trying to just be mean to your mom
I I'm disrespecting I'm disrespecting
her because her behaviors are awful
but I'm not trying to be mean to her she
needs to change her behavior so that she
has a quality life she's 58 freaking
years old there's nothing wrong with
this woman she could get a job and pay
her bills instead of mooching off her 28
year old son
and so she it's good for her she's gonna
like herself better all the other
brothers and sisters are going to like
her better
um everybody's gonna be a lot happier
when Mom gets her crap together
am I missing something
no no I think that's right I guess yeah
it's kind of like you said just trying
to figure out the the best way to do
about it without you know being mean
you're not being mean
when you don't give a drunk a drink it's
not good for a drunk to have a bottle of
Jack Daniels
it's not good for a heroin addict to be
to be loaded up with Heroin it's not
good for them they don't like it when
you tell them no
but it's not good for them this is not
good for your mom loving your mom well
is helping her get a life that is not
filled with chaos A Life That's not
filled with uncertainty and a life
that's not on that's not sustainable and
it doesn't have any dignity
and so um now again I don't you know
you're not being mean now she's going to
tell you you're being mean that's so
mean you have plenty of money what's
wrong with you Tyler I raised you you
can give me a little
that's what it sounds like yeah that's
exactly what it's going to sound like
coming back at you that's called a
travel agent for guilt trips she's going
to pitch one on you I'd be more worried
about upsetting my wife than I would be
upsetting my mom and I think that's what
this is going to come down I would be
worried that I'm doing harm to my own
mother who I love and there's that too
and when you support the misbehavior
you're doing harm to them enablers are
not helpers
they're cowards who won't say no that's
what they are don't be a coward love
hurt well enough that you help her
for real helper
and if you want to put her through
Financial Peace University you call our
team will give it to you this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsey win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality is my co-host today the
phone number here is triple eight eight
two five five two two five thank you for
joining us Robin is in Phoenix hi Robin
welcome to the Ramsay show
fine thank you Jeremy for taking my call
sure I am going to retire in about three
years at 76. I have no mutual funds no
401K my question is should I buy or rent
at that time at 76.
okay
how would you be able to buy if you
don't have any money
yeah well I've got these I've got time
so currently my income is 4 500 a month
2K is going to rent 2K is going to
student loans and five
um I'd spend 500 on
um daily on on that living you know
living expenses you're 70 years old and
you have a student loan
yes
and haven't paid it off yet but I will
pay it off it's expected to be paid off
in March of 24.
okay what's the balance on it
twelve thousand
so I'm paying 2 000 a month on that
2K 2K1 all right I'm really curious how
you end up with a student loan at your
age how did you do that
whether it's called pain the interest
I paid the interest only for a long time
so what's a long time
since 2020 since 2005 I guess
that's when I graduated you graduated in
in 05 so you graduated 20 years or 18
years ago
and you've been paying and your degree
is in what
a bet that particular degree that's I've
got some more since that time but that
particular degree was in Communications
okay all right and what do you do for a
living
I'm a Quality Inspector
wow
all right
um
the the thing that runs through my head
is this I obviously you at retirement
have to have monthly money to pay an
electric bill and buy food
and uh provide shelter okay
uh the largest line item in your budget
for the rest of your life if you live to
be 95 another 20 something years
is going to be
um housing
and if you're renting
your cost of housing is going to go up
every year because rent always goes up
does that make sense yeah if you buy at
least you're locked into what you're
going to be spending on housing from
this point forward
so buying is good having a paid off home
by the time you get there is even better
and of course having a nest egg to live
on so do you have a pension in the
background of this or are you counting
on just Social Security to feed you
no
um I'll finish the rest um so right
current ly what I have is a universal
life policy that has a cash value
approximately 9 000 in it I'm reluctant
to cash it out because it has a
long-term care Rider of 50 months on it
at four percent so that's going to give
me uh 15 about 1500 a month just for
that now as I share
um at the End by the time I retire I
will have approximately 500 in pension
and 2500 I'm guessing 2500 in Social
Security which are giving three thousand
and I knew I have no money in savings
at all my thousand dollars one thousand
I got my thousand okay all right I want
you to catch the universal in and pay
the student loan down and let's be done
with the student loan very quickly let's
get that in the background as soon as
possible so we can try to accomplish a
couple of these other goals which is
housing and start to build some kind of
a nest egg over the next three years so
basically you're going to live on beans
and rice for the next three years while
you throw as much money towards housing
buying a home and as much money towards
a nest egg as you can throw
and both of those are going to be better
moves than a bad Universal policy so
we've got to get the student loan in
your rearview mirror to pull that off
okay get the student loan in your
rearview mirror build an emergency fund
and then start saving for a down payment
while you're putting at least 15 percent
of your income or more into retirement
and I want you to save as much as you
can save for retirement while putting
down as much as you can put down on a
house and and when you do buy a home I
want you to buy a very modest a very
inexpensive property
I am more concerned that you have basic
shelter that is locked in on its monthly
cost than I am you having a home that
you are necessarily thrilled with
okay that makes sense yeah I want to
stabilize I'm trying to stabilize your
future that's what I'm that's my first
goal your luxury or your comfort are
secondary but stabilizing the shelter
aspects of your future next 20 years is
really what I got to lean on and uh wow
wow well the good news is I think you
can actually make a pretty good dent in
36 months on this if you'll be very
focused
um
I think that might be one of the oldest
student loan deck callers I've had it's
it's mind-boggling I'm sitting there
listening to that and because we're
having the student loan live stream
tonight uh it's absolutely free
ramseysolutions.com 7 P.M Central 8
Eastern it's important to point out that
she is and I don't throw this word
around lightly you know this Dave she's
a victim of this cultural
message that is said if you get a degree
you're gonna get a raise and sometimes
that's true many times it's not and she
can't really agree degrees in in degrees
Communications and I'm not in
Communications exactly she's in quality
assurance and so you've got to be
careful these degrees don't come with
jobs you still got to go out and find
them get them and perform them well and
I I'm not I'm not trying to be unkind
but there are so many people that still
believe uh you go through a layoff at 45
or at 50 and you go I gotta go get more
education maybe but probably not
probably not yeah
not at the cost of sitting at 70 years
old stuff student London no and see
that's the exchange that makes me so
angry about
and let me just be honest let me be an
equal opportunity offender folks both
sides of the political aisle are in the
business of student loans it's big
business it's a lot of money and no
one's talking about legislation or
regulation to stop it to stop it and to
take on the unbelievable inflation this
is in the world of tuition doing a
service no
you people in government are not helping
that's right the population you are
harming the people that your car called
to govern it's a hidden text and and
people are getting filthy stinking rich
off the backs of people like her and
it's really does need to stop it really
I mean seriously would somebody grow a
leadership backbone and send it to
Washington D.C ah this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Dr John deloney has a
brand new book coming out called the
building a non-anxious life you can
pre-order the book right now for twenty
dollars and you'll get 75 dollars in
bonus items nearly half the US
population says their lives are affected
by anxiety stress burnout it's
everywhere but here's the thing anxiety
isn't actually the problem
it's the symptom
the problem is we're unsafe disconnected
unhealthy living like we have no say in
what happens next and in this book Dr
deloney walks you through six daily
choices to recognize and break free from
A Life That's spinning out of control
it is amazing this book is selling like
hotcakes too and we it comes out
technically October 3rd if you pre-order
you get 75 in bonus items which includes
instant access to one of Dr John's talks
newest talk smoke fire and freedom that
is a great talk and also you're going to
get the e-book the audiobook
ramseysolutions.com building a
non-anxious life Christopher is in
Corpus Christi Texas hi Christopher
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave Lincoln thank you for having me
on sure what's up
so I'll give you a quick back story I'm
recently engaged our weddings in June I
have a full-time job making 34 000 a
year I also go to school full-time to be
a radiology tech
I have no debt and I have an emergency
phone at 20K me and my fiance are on the
same page about not going into debt for
the wedding and not spending more than
5K on our budget for the wedding I
recently made it to step four but I'm
confused if I should be investing 15
while also saving for a wedding and a
bouncing out of home
no you ought to be saving for the
wedding and for your education until
you're married don't worry about a home
and don't worry about retirement right
now
okay you'll get you got time to get to
both right now you need to get married
pay cash for the wedding and uh even if
you beef up the budget a little bit
that's okay your budget's not out of
control on this wedding and
um make sure you get through this school
and pay cash for all of it so you need
the margin in your life to just be
piling up cash right now until June
right yeah let's worry about it
retirement and worry about buying a
house a year or two from now
okay so I should just be saving for the
wedding and for your life yeah just pile
up money right now I want you to get I
want you to get your education finished
I want you to get married lower lower
stress on both of these with a big old
pile of cash and then when you get out
and the wedding is over if you've got a
little money left over that's your head
start towards your emergency fund and
towards your down payment
but you're there's no don't don't you're
putting too much pressure on yourself
try to do all these things at once
how old are you
I'm 24. you got plenty of time you're
gonna be okay Crystal I can hear your
brain you're processing what Dave's
saying but it's it you're something's
got you hung up what's going on
nothing I just you're just goal oriented
yeah
yeah I started school late
I just I'm doing my Basics right now and
my remedial courses so I feel like I
kind of started late in the game so you
feel like you're behind yeah you're not
yeah you're not you're you're way ahead
because you actually know what you want
to do that's right and you got it you're
running down a very clearly defined
track your plan you laid it out
perfectly in just a few moments on the
air here in front of 20 million people
that's impressive I mean you really yeah
that's a great job you're doing a whole
lot better than it feels like you're
doing you're going to get to the other
things I'm not saying don't do them I'm
just saying don't worry about them now a
year from now two years from now we'll
worry about those right now pay cash for
the wedding finish your degree pay cash
for that pile up money that's all you
need to do right now that and that's
plenty it's plenty making 34k that's a
big enough task as it is yeah you can do
it all but not at the same time and I
think that's pretty much true uh in any
area of life so you're going to be okay
and give yourself a break I there's I
could feel him beating up on himself a
little bit I'm behind I'm behind yeah no
you'll be okay yeah you're not the fact
of the matter is with our plan you're
going to catch up with a lot of people
no you're probably by March yeah but you
know why he's a tortoise and he's
focused and the Tortoise always wins
that race every time you're exactly
right Jeremy's in Houston hi Jeremy
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi thanks for having me sure what's up
yeah so my primary question today uh and
I probably just need to hear you say it
is trying to work out how much house I
can really afford because when I start
to look at the numbers I begin to feel
like maybe I'm going a little bit crazy
and then it just kind of spirals into
should I ever even think about buying a
place or should I rent forever
uh-huh
well that's a false narrative you don't
have to rent forever that's not a real
option you know that's just drama queen
sound dramatic actually I don't
necessarily know what I mean that
happens we have a little drama all of us
have a little drama queen in our head
and that one's that when you spiral out
like that that's the little drama queen
in your head I mean you know you're not
going to rent forever and you know
that's dumb because rent goes up every
year so renting is a good short-term
plan but it's not a good long-term plan
you already knew that right
I I sort of I sort of knew that but I
didn't actually feel that renting was
necessarily I don't mean it in negative
connotation oh it's negative it's not a
good idea long term I'll give it to you
negative it's here's why it's negative
it's not because it's a class status
thing it's because your cost of housing
goes up every year for 45 or 50 years
you're going to pay more every single
year if you rent
and that's that's a death nail to your
finances versus if you own the value of
the home is going up and if you're
making a payment on a fixed rate 15 year
that we tell you to do the payment is
locked in the only reason it would
change is taxes insurance but it won't
change otherwise and so you've locked in
the largest line item in your budget
which is housing and it's going up in
value versus nothing is going up in
value when you're renting long term and
it and your rent goes up every stinking
year the largest line item in your
budget takes up more of your money every
year so you don't want to do that long
term but you may want to do it for a
year or two while you get some other
things done like getting out of debt and
getting your emergency fund in place and
and then
um
let me just tell you uh one of the
things you experience when you learn to
live debt free is is that you are living
like no one else so that later you can
live and give like no one else and when
you live within a reasonable Budget on
housing there's going to be people
around you that are buying a nicer house
on a 30-year adjustable rate mortgage
maxing themselves out where they can't
breathe and they're taking on a house
payment that is crazy as a percentage of
their income
and they don't make any more than you
make and it looks like they're winning
they're not winning they're destroying
themselves
and meanwhile you're over here uh in in
a much more modest property feeling like
you're losing and the reality is you're
winning does that any that sound right
no it does sound right and and you know
the numbers make me feel a little bit
crazy because I feel like I earn a
pretty good living my situation
I make after taxes about 140 after taxes
after 401K about 140 000 a year okay
well we say we should put a 15-year
fixed rate no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay and that's not counting
401K that's just taxes coming out of
your take-home pay so what's your take
on pay not counting 401k and a 15-year
fixed rate interest rates are higher now
than they were this time last year
obviously uh the good that's the bad
news the good news is that that um you
know well there's a shortage of housing
so we're still seeing house prices go up
but you can find a house you probably
can get a seller to give you some
attention right now
my inventory is really low but um which
is holding the prices up but the um
but if you can find a house you know if
you're out of debt and you have your
emergency fund you have a good down
payment you're going to buy something
more conservative than your peers no
question about it no but again it's not
it's it's the long game that's the
definition of winning is not don't
follow your broke friends right
it's not how fast you come out of the
gate it's how you finish and and got to
remember that it's so you're not making
500 a year you're making 140 a year
I mean it's a lot of money it's a lot
it's double the household income average
but it's only double it's not 4X and
it's not 6X so you know the average
house price in your area plus a little
that's what you're going to be getting
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
on the debt free stage Nick and Laura
are with us hey guys how are you good
how are you Dave better than I deserve
where do you guys live San Bernardino
California oh fun welcome to Nashville
and here to do a debt free scream how
much have you paid off 223
000. I love it and how long did that
take 99 months 99 months look at you and
uh your range of income during that 99
months we started at 71 000 and ended at
195. very cool what do you all do for a
living
well I am a homeschool mom and I also do
real estate on the side and I work for
the County local government there okay
very good well you guys are doing well
so 99 months 223 is this your house
this is everything Dave one to seven
paid off
everything look at it where
I mean you
live a paid four house yes this is a big
deal what's this house worth a little
over six hundred thousand I bet it is
I love it congratulations ding ding how
much you guys got in your Investments
for retirement and so forth uh we have
about 150 in roths and about 200 in a
pension no all right so that puts you at
millionaire status doesn't it right
there baby steps millionaires right on
the line anyway yeah yeah really close
if we throw in the furniture we're there
yeah yeah all right there's not much
Furniture David
way to go guys congratulations how old
are you
42 42 42 42 and a paid for house and
basically baby steps millionaires I'm so
proud of y'all thank you tell us the
story what happened 99 months ago how
did you get connected with this Ramsay
stuff
well we uh I listened to you when I was
younger
um probably when we were both younger
Dave
and I was doing good and and uh we were
moving in the right direction I worked
for a bank and we went South we went on
the borrowing Trend and uh we borrowed
everything we could we wood burning
stoves credit cards everything else you
can do somewhere along the lines we just
started going negative every month every
month we were
you know we were losing money we were
just not saving we were just going red
red red red until one day I realized I
couldn't pay couldn't put gas in my car
without putting on a credit card I felt
like a loser felt like a pretty bad
father because we had just had uh two
beautiful girls and I kind of remembered
everything I listened to on the radio
went back and and uh restarted
um in our mid-30s and then we suffered a
lot over the last eight years and here
we are so
so Laura he walks in and goes uh this
isn't working what'd you say I said okay
well how do we fix it and he said oh
well there's this Dave Ramsey guy and he
has this plan and we're gonna have to
cut everything I'm gonna sell my dream
truck and I said oh hard pass
I don't think so that sounds terrible
actually you know I had two babies and I
I didn't want to do it but I I wanted to
support my husband and so I did it for
about nine months without my heart in it
but I did it you know to the letter and
then one day we were sitting at the
dining room table and we paid off our
car and I looked up and I said oh my
gosh this could work
this is amazing light comes on it came
on and I started listening to the show
and you know it was Game On from there
my heart was in it and then it was
different you know from then on yeah wow
wow so you took nine months of you kind
of dragging her along huh yeah and then
she shows okay wait a minute dad gum
this stuff is yeah okay oh I need
something here Nick I picked up on the
word suffering which was a little bit
sarcastic but yeah yeah but I I think
he's actually there's probably a lot of
Truth to that and and and I want people
to hear it's not easy how difficult this
was for you guys but how it feels on the
other side so give us a little window
into what's suffering even sarcastically
meant well I always joke that Dave
Ramsey ruined my life yeah there's a
whole internet channel on that
but the truth is I mean you're going to
see your friends they're going to be
buying trucks and they're going to be
drive driving side by sides down the
road and and they're gonna be having a
lot of fun and there's gonna be a time
where you have to suck it up and you
have to say I'm gonna get something I'm
not gonna I'm gonna say no
um I I think for your normal working
family you have to pay a price
um if you just if you just wander
through you'll wander right into debt
just like every all the Joneses and
you'll be comparing yourself so I think
there's just a time where you have to
have discipline and you have to say hey
this is hard but it's the best best
thing for my future for my girls you
know for for the rest of my life and so
that's where where your temporary
Pleasures I think we
we had to put aside for a minute and we
had to focus on our goal which took a
long time took eight years so what's the
dream now 42 and you guys are debt free
house and everything well how does that
change your vision well our first dream
was to come to Nashville to check it off
the Box you're there one down yeah so
next stream yeah I watched a lot of debt
free screams and I always thought it
would make it we're going yeah I like it
I'm glad you're here yeah I was so proud
of you it's a good deal so what is the
next big thing yeah
for me you know the next biggest thing
is to set up my girls for uh success you
know in a just a better platform to
build off of than I had I'm from a
single wide trailer even though it's in
California
um and I just want better for them so
for me the future is trying to build for
them and then us enjoying our lives a
little bit more yeah absolutely and and
really being an opportunity to give and
and affect people in a better way yeah
well congratulations I guess Dave
there's probably a nice truck in the
future though I would hope I think he's
he's earned it yeah maybe it's on this
side he's a millionaire yeah 22. come on
come on pay cash for it get you a toy
yeah that's good that you all should you
should enjoy some of this and you should
give some of it and you should use some
of it for investing and uh building up
the future and changing your family tree
and you will so very very well done very
proud of y'all what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is
avoiding lifestyle creep and was
something that I feel that we did really
well over the eight years you know Nick
had a lot of promotions and a lot of pay
raises I had a few commission checks
come in and they pretty much went all to
the mortgage and that was hard when you
see other people unrewarding it's very
unrewarding and it's it's hard after a
while and you just say oh I just want to
do x y z whatever it is and we just
didn't we just kept saying no you know
we want to pay a price to win and and
over the course of the eight years we
spent the first four years in baby steps
one through five and
you know three four five felt like it
took a really long time to get through
we really just kind of crawled through
those and those were you know hard slow
years and then we paid off 180 in the
last four years whoa so it really kind
of picked up at the end yeah and that's
well your income changed during that the
income changed everything changed we
were working together and the snowball
really got going it was it was really
neat to see that way to go you guys
congratulations thanks we did a tracking
process as well we kind of bought these
hurricane lamps and we put some smooth
stones in them each Stone was 500 so at
the end of the budget
meeting at the end of the month we would
you know see how much we could put in
towards it and we would bring the girls
in and we'd each put a rock in and
sometimes we only put two and sometimes
we put 15. yeah you know but it was it
was something that we brought them in
for and we would talk about you know why
are we even doing this and what is dead
and why is this important and so bring
them up let's introduce them what are
their names and ages so we got two of
them here oldest is uh Sabrina yeah it's
just Cassidy great hey we've got the
live and give box for you the baby steps
millionaires book which is what you've
done congratulations The Total Money
Makeover book and a Financial Peace
University membership for you to either
enjoy or give any of it just our way of
saying thanks for you to come and people
buy that and give that stuff away all
the time so thank you guys so very proud
of you Nick and Laura Sabrina and
Cassidy San Bernardino California 223
000 paid off in 99 months making 71 to
195. Baby Steps millionaires at 42 count
it down let's you're a debt-free scream
are you ready three two one
[Music]
yeah
oh you gotta love it
man oh man those little girls have a mom
and daddy that changed their lives yeah
well done that's grown-up stuff there
boys and girls this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
12 15 the way of a fool is right in his
own eyes but a wise man listens to
advice Tommy Lasorda says the only
problem with success is that it does not
teach you how to deal with failure Joe
is with us Joe is in Cincinnati hi Joe
how are you
I am fantastic
how can we help
all right now I've got a question I've
been pretty intently saving uh to buy a
new Bronco even selling my early Bronco
and through my intensity and focus I've
actually saved up enough to pay off my
home and now I'm struggling do I
continue on with my plan to buy my
Bronco or pay off my house wow that's
cool those Broncos are cool
so what do you make
uh about 150. what's the Bronco cost
uh it's 56. okay and you can pay off
your house I'm A Car Guys you pay off
your house
yes you have a couple of other cars
yeah I've got a an old classic from my
father-in-law and then uh early Bronco
that I've also had for about 35 years
that the value has increased on it also
oh yeah those things are through the
roof yeah
yeah that's fun
um
well it's a simple question that you
have to answer for yourself I don't
think anyone else can answer it for you
what do you want more a new Bronco or a
paid off house
and um
I'm the other side of all of that
um let me just tell you this too it's
not it's not a permanent choice
it's which one do you want first yeah
because if you buy the paid off Bronco
then your next goal is you're going to
pay off the house and you make good
money and you're going to pay it off
fairly quick right
yes or if you pay off your house if you
pay off the house you don't have a house
payment
um and now we can save like crazy and
buy a new Bronco
so I mean my guess is is that
um two years from today you've
accomplished both goals agreed
yes so just which one do you want for
the next two years because the other
one's going to wait 18 months to two
years
yeah I'm also struggling because I've
drove junk for years uh
and even a free car to keep it going
just so I can do something and I'm
struggling spending that much money
thinking of spending that much money on
a vehicle now it's always what I thought
I wanted you know it comes down to uh
letting it go for that I don't know
uh you're not getting rid of the other
two Classics right
no okay good I was gonna say I love the
old Bronco more than the new one but
this is your money yeah oh I wouldn't
make the trade I'd keep those two and
then add the new one to the mix the new
one's a cool car it's it's a neat car
um
are you driving something that you're
not proud of right now is that why you
probably he's driving one of those
Classics aren't you
uh no right now I'm driving about a
eight thousand dollar car I upgraded
last year from my freebie junker uh so I
upgraded uh in the meantime to save up
for a Bronco I've just been able to save
up sooner than I thought what's the uh
what's the balance on your house exactly
uh 72 000.
and you have 56 in the Bronco account or
what
by General savings uh we actually have
about uh I think uh 70 liquid right now
not counting our emergency fund what's
in the emergency fund
uh we keep about 20 in there and it's
normally low but I've retired military
so I've got a pension a good pension
that comes in monthly so
things
I love the car I love the Bronco I think
they're cool cars I don't own one of
them I think they're a very cool car I
can understand where you're coming from
having said that I personally would wait
18 months to buy the new Bronco and I
would pay off my house
uh but the point is you're going to do
both within 24 months
and you need to have a game plan to do
that it's just a matter of which one
goes first that's the only choice we're
making we're not making a choice of
Bronco versus house we're making a
choice of which one comes first in the
24 month calendar
and that helps me that helps me make the
decision to do the house does that make
sense
yes and then then you're going to feel a
little wiser spending this much on a car
than you feel right now you feel like
you're over doing it a little bit right
now because that house is still dangling
out there and if you do the house first
in the Broncos second the Broncos not
going to come with as much guilt yeah
and if if that older Bronco is pretty
slick I'd get rid of the eight thousand
dollar car sell it drive the sweet
Bronco around if you want to upgrade you
you've worked hard I get what he's
saying he's like I've been driving crap
for so long and now I kind of want to
drive something nice but I'm with you
that house is going up in value the
Bronco he buys will not no no
no it's not I know the old one did but
you're not going to keep this one 45
years that's probably going to be that's
correct thing so and it's not uh 1800
bucks which is what you paid for the
other ones exactly right back in the day
or whatever whatever it was yeah I would
be driving that old Bronco all right it
depends on you know you don't mess it up
you don't put miles on it yeah I'm not a
daily driver Joe's in Cincinnati Hey Joe
what's up
yeah hi hi Joe thanks guys all right
Brian is in Los Angeles let's try that
hey Brian how are you
sure I'm doing great thank you for the
time to be on here today I've been a big
listener to you guys for a while man
because the year I got out of debt a
couple years ago but um my question
today is I'm married I have two boys we
live in Los Angeles County and my
question is uh we make a good income
here and um however we're very
unsatisfied with the quality of life
here just the school values the crime
the homelessness and all in all just
young Christian Society so we're
considering relocating to another state
um such as either Tennessee or Idaho or
a few others
um the issue is that
um our my projected income would
probably be cut close to being in half
why
so I'm a police officer in L.A county
and with overtime I usually bring around
140 to 150 a year and the same salary in
those areas are are a good bit less
maybe like 60 of that yeah
you're comparing overtime to know
overtime also yep it's not half but it
is in in your field it is substantially
less yeah but it's also worth just
kicking the tires in other states you
know what would an Atlanta metro
situation that's not the greatest thing
in the world but it's the cost of living
would be less than La look at multiple
States in a region to kind of see what
your opportunities are
how long you been on the force
uh that's another thing 12 years
does that qualify you for moving into
like a a highway patrol role in one of
the states because those do pay a lot
more than the state you're talking about
any type of law enforcement be field in
any other state but just comparing it to
California just it truly is a
significant not necessarily how much
research necessarily on this and I'm
gonna tell you why I covered this story
recently the Fraternal Order of Police
uh they are having a hard time
recruiting police officers you
understand why I don't need to get into
that and there's a great opportunity
right now for you with 12 years of
experience in Los Angeles County I think
you need to do more research and see
what your opportunities for uh transfer
would look like and then growth and Dave
makes a very good point moving into
signing bonuses available yeah and
moving into a State Police role uh in
another region of the country could be
really looking and that would not
necessarily be a pay cut then yeah I
mean you move into a Bureau of
Investigation in one of the states like
Tennessee TBI or something like that
um but I would get out that's the heart
of his question I would get out if I
felt the way that you set it up to Dave
and I I would get out I think you're
um moving but I think you've got to do a
little bit more work on the career side
so that it isn't as big a cut as you
perceive it to be that's correct because
that what you're outlining at first
blush is true I mean if you compare it
to an outlying County or something like
that in uh you know in a Texas a
Tennessee or what Florida whatever you
might you might uh you might see that
bigger cut but there's ways to get into
a Metro situation there's ways to get in
the state situations and with your
experience you might move in move up
several
um
let pay levels uh in one of those States
and actually come out fairly close and
there's overtime available everywhere in
your world tell you what high school
football games and church on Sunday
morning
everywhere police everywhere no hey man
we appreciate you stay safe out there
that puts this hour of the Ramsay show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
foreign
all of our shows with the Ramsay Network
app on your smartphone it's the only
place to listen to the entire back
catalog of episodes download the Ramsay
Network app in your favorite app store
today
foreign
[Music]